what I do is more than manicure it's
micro activism you can be cute and
multi-faceted and vocal about your
message my name is Aimee Vega and I'm a
nail artist out of New York City I
became a nail artist by chance it was
always something I did for myself since
I was maybe 13 years old and I thought
about it and I wanted to pursue it more
seriously so I went to nail school I got
my license so I work on fashion shoes
but neon is mostly what I do
I think socially conscious nail art is
important now more than ever because of
the things going on not just in our
country but all around the world
everything under like lives matter'
women's rights LGBT rights women's
health domestic violence against women
is also another one no matter what you
have on your nails they bring attention
it brings your eyes to their nails it
kind of brings the conversation is a
real life nowadays we depend so much on
social media and it kind of just brings
that interaction of person to person
somebody will see a nail art and want to
inquire and then you have a moment and
opportunity to talk about that topic
it's more than just being cute and
having cute nails it's having a message
and feeling strong about it and be vocal
about it as a woman sometimes we're made
to be a bit more submissive and this is
a way of kind of getting strength in our
own messages and saying hey I am going
to be cute I also have a message to say
and I'm wearing on my fingers now so be
an activist means to feel strongly about
something whatever it may be more than
anything staying true to yourself and
your message
[Music]
so the next group jamaican-born but they
came up in the UK both of where our
hip-hop artists and personal assistants
to have together for poetic pilgrimage
how you guys doing someone's just
homeless a they like hold on we're
connected to two very misunderstood
realities one being hip-hop and one
being Islam and I think for us is quite
a cosmic even though we didn't set out
to be this bridge between any two
communities in a way I think we kind of
are so many people have inaccurate ideas
of what being a Muslim is and what being
a Muslim women is about so we need to
express ourselves because if you don't
then other people would speak for us
it's important within women's voices to
be heard because we are so often spoken
about our relationship with hip-hop is
the genesis of hip-hop in fact giving
that voice to the people that were
voiceless is about representing the
under-represented important form of the
moment to be present in places that we
don't expect it to be because I think
that that's where change happens with
cortical image we strive to change our
world and our reality in hopes that it
will have a ripple effect in changing
how the wider community view women
Muslims less women
we're just trying to be an embodiment of
that and hope that it will change the
world
[Music]
I just see that I'm a person that has
something to say and instead of saying
this and using words says it by just
putting some paint on the surface
[Music]
my name is Nahal Ronnie and I'm a street
artist from Belize
the reason I paint portraits or figures
that kind of show our Arab culture is
very simple when I started painting all
over the city I used to have to remove
photos of politicians and political
logos and election posters these
politicians one Lester legalize their
job occupy most of the urban landscape
and this is where I actually wanted to
replace them with something more
positive that the citizens have a route
that the presence of these people is
really optional there is a very
complicated question of identity when it
comes to what does it mean to be
Lebanese
and this is another reason why I think
these faces they represent the stories
of Lebanon Beirut and the Arab world in
general a mural can make a war not only
a war but maybe something that creates a
relationship of people with a with an
element in this Creek and I think it
kind of spreads positivity and changes
the perspective of people from their
everyday life I really appreciate that
the people that compared me to Banksy I
really appreciate Vance's work and I
think it's smart it's the wiki and he
has a lot of credit when it comes to the
global street art movement I don't paint
just for the sake of painting or for the
sake of capitalizing on a certain event
I just think when I feel that I have
something constructive to say
a graffiti Staunton malice quito's
directional eponymous comedy maad
Nocenti ending que la gente legal Oski
era pero que no Vega viendo una falter
towed raffia a una foto de respecto
[Music]
somos Axio no to graphic equipo de
camões a concealed assault a tempered
raffia y de gramática en la piel de las
calles de nuestra cidade mejor ahmo's
del mundo tengo de puntos inada vez lo
que nos motivo empezar todo esto y este
graffiti que estaba tan mal escrito que
pasa commenced a few como un aperitivo
moral si una pelota de comprar una una
Lata display Rojo yo Rahila salsas
desirous ET pour Kiera aaron burr ostomy
es una cosa que no no debe most roll era
tipo interventions nosotros somos el
vandalism oh yeah perfect Rado ainsi que
nosotros nosotros implementing llamo
Zecora here a que yo quenette a graffiti
yes tamil no so Treme's ahmo's por una
pair yes a parade knows Devo
I'm Clare College in Los Altos de raffia
en el barrio eso no slave om star Cora
he does falter safe en esta ciudad para
approach a momentum este pais en el
mundo y SI vamos via pocket
let us see that study another romantic
Oh instantly I muchísimo graffiti
romantic honestly dad muchisimas
mensajes de mas e Clara San Mele split
to the second o'hagan como vivienda very
convivial correspond to the road el
momento Indian ketosis those Daniels
moment ora kia parte de Sol Sabean sang
Kratos grupos and Tedesco Madrid a way
he'll también la escritura Monteverde
Mexico de rosario de dueño de de de
mucho cidades de de latin america
d'espagne Mucha gente de hecho no
distrito parent ando como puede hacer
para pasar el movimiento de squishiest u
da di como nosotros gmos esto la
cuestión de la compress pay Rojo station
extensive básicamente empezar
intervention nosotros resin demo search
a la ciudad same as Amina's hamas vesta
más interesante
mess Cosmo philippa nosotros NOS phallus
diremos hasta en un mundo libre juan de
los loros mode obliga DM [ __ ] Ramona
[Music]
[Music]
aleppo citadel the ancient city of
Palmyra and the nuria's of Hamas all
ancient heritage sites and all destroyed
in the Syrian war it's a loss not only
to Syrians but to the entire world and
these refugee artists are finding their
own way to rebuild what has been lost
vamanos Tamara was put in the hole where
my holy place for them and then of
Solaria enough sin law I mean that's an
even wider it and whatever pluma de Lima
sort they have been using found
materials such as wood clay and even
kabob skewers to make scale models of
these historical landmarks
Bustamante Allah saw mercury chaos at
Meharry she their work is a way to
preserve Syrian history and educate the
world about the conflict at Sarah Mary
Sarah de Elemeno well Azam's dr. Harb
Surya
Donna Haram Noel Jabara Fatima inverted
Dahmer Petula hey Virgil Muhammad Ali a
thermal are afraid she can't read al
dila Hawara Sarita about a fraternity
the mo of the United
[Music]
I will say Jerusalem was to Shui with a
queen chosen value for ahem personable
and sure oral extra remember plena
bedycasa Binodini the officers say that
by making this work they are drawing
attention and giving what they can to
the people of Syria and Iran mimic that
Megan Tamara sooravali any actor hajima
an animal Judean Brittani normally Anna
Megan nama saya
[Music]